by the way when i take seven grams of
mushrooms everything i do we split she
takes seven i take seven she's a junior
what happened when we were sitting in my
bed just tripping did i talk to my mom
for years i caught i [ __ ] had like a
spark in my head and i called my mom and
i [ __ ] squashed it and then i'm like
yo you're about to talk to my mom first
time insurance on [ __ ] mushrooms in
person in person because i don't [ __ ]
with her i don't call my [ __ ] house
hold on hold on i know you guys were
just in the room looking at the [ __ ]
no i called my mom and called her to
[ __ ] come over and i squashed it
did she know you guys were tripping
balls
she sits there and goes
what's wrong with you guys
and i look here and go i'm so [ __ ] up
on mushrooms right now man she goes
that's why they called me i go yeah i
had a thing in my head that goes yeah
you need to squash it that's why you're
here
can we be friends now and then she's
like
you guys are that [ __ ] up and i looked
at rosie or she ate as much as i did